it's time for screen junkies movie
fights movie fights movie fights will be
fights guys we're back what's going on
y'all welcome to movie fights another
stellar edition of America's favorite
movie based game show thank you for
joining
how odd Nick I'll be your host today and
we have oh we got some og screen junkies
movie fights competitors who are ready
to throw down
let's welcome first to the panel oh he's
the writer of Wonder Woman 77
he's an Eisner Comic Book Award winner
oh wait welcome mark and Draco to have
you mark yeah so what are you writing
right now right now as we wait now I'm
finishing up a steampunk Red Sonja book
a sequel to a body called legendary Red
Sonja Queen and then the Harley Quinn
and poison ivy meat bedding Veronica
that I wrote with Paul Dini just
finished that'll be collected in the
hardcover in a couple of months that
sounds awesome
it is really awesome if you can catch
they're there all you can buy most of
them they are amazing and if I hear
correctly this weekend maybe it's C to
eat through some super big project I'm
working on will be announced okay how
about a movie fights exclusive there are
snipers from the company that I'm
working for outside that company takes
things a little too seriously mark thank
you for being here very exciting
oh you know him you love them he's super
funny
hashtag Botanica s' mr. Mike Carlson hi
hi hello there L how are you
Mike what are you writing right now I
also have a lot of announcements at c2e2
this week but they will not be in any of
the panels that's fine don't define me
and I will announce it loudly heck yeah
okay I have a podcast though yeah plug
that a lot of it it's called podcast the
ride it's about theme parks we're in the
middle of a two-part episode about the
failed hardrock theme park oh there was
a 400 million dollar Hard Rock Park with
Led Zeppelin the ride and ride based on
the moody blues song nights in white
satin'
which is real this is 100% real and it
supposedly was a great ride and we're in
the middle of talking about it with
guest Jason Wallner here's a fun fact no
one in our audience has heard of the
mood booze I believe that there's an old
band like the 60s and 70s cure
grandparents about him yeah
they're going into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame this year though Wow that
sounds awesome
you should have you ever done an episode
about all the people that have been
thrown off rides and fatalities we
haven't gotten there we're not even six
months in so we're gonna save that one
for maybe when we've run out of some
ideas yeah that would be a dark yeah
Mike Carlson always great to have him on
man whoo and whoa I thought I got very
confused because usually I look over
somewhere else I see Danielle but
Danielle you've jumped into the ring
today throw down
Daniel Radford well I'm excited to have
you Roscoe okay I don't like fighting I
am a peace-loving woman I don't know how
this is gonna work because I'm probably
gonna spend the whole time being like
you know what that's a really good point
okay then
well I'm sure you'll bring up some great
points of your own and I'm sure you'll
throw down and I know you are the host
why don't you plug your podcast I know
you hope it's an exciting wrestling
podcast my podcast well this is great
because it's also WrestleMania weekend
my podcast is called tights and fights
were on the max fun Network and we
talked about last thing and it is great
um we I think an episode just dropped
like probably right now we're getting
ready to go into WrestleMania my bays
and so everyone I I don't see Joe start
but in my heart I'm just gonna pretend
like I do and I'm just gonna give him
one of these that's how I accused yeah -
sweet
Oh Joe star guy - sweet him.we ways
don't get really mad but like it's okay
- sweets for everyone there we go
awesome you'll be mad - sweets for
everyone I find no idea what you just
did it's a wrestling thing and Danielle
how could we get mad at you because you
are too sweet thank you for being here
today's show is judged by three of us
myself and we got the damn cam featuring
Dan Merle welcome
to the party pal oh happy to be here oh
of course
so um you are going to be checking some
stuff throughout the show you checking
the facts and I'll be making my judgment
based on accuracy based on debate style
and arbitrarily just like you thank you
sir exactly and next to Dan and she will
be holding it down on the social media
she's the voice of the people today I
was a little nervous because we didn't
have Danielle but we're not gonna miss a
beat because we have the super excellent
and wonderful Roth cornet she is an
honorary dan and you respect her the way
you respect anyone in the damn camp I'm
an official dan today yes you are so
that's pretty exciting Dan's already
been doing a little fact checking on the
Moody Blues here did you know the nights
in white satin' ride was four minutes
and 45 seconds long I do have rules for
us and information please I'm gonna read
it so do vote in the polls which we want
you to do because that's how we're gonna
break the tie if there is a tie between
Hal and Dan you guys get to decide you
have to use the AI cards which are
located at the top right corner of the
video the little eye and a circle around
it each round you have to reset the new
poll by clicking the Settings wheel and
turning your ATandT annotations on again
and off again or you can also refresh
the whole video if you happen to love
ads which we know that you do if you are
confused by any of these instructions
and you likely are there are
instructions in the description box
please do vote that's how we will break
the ties and decide the winner from this
movie is so good at this
yep and please in addition to voting and
commenting and all that stuff send us
comments and memes preferably dankmemes
thank you I'm trying to keep and send
this woman a corgi send Daniel Corgi all
right you know what we've gibberish
yes folks we've jibber-jabber enough I
think it might be time to fight jte
dropped that sick ass package
ladies and gents
[Music]
[Applause]
yes jte best package in the biz so as a
reminder for y'all going there that yeah
don't judge so as a reminder y'all we
have three regular questions that will
be decided by myself Dan and Roth going
by your YouTube poll after three rounds
we go to a speed round where there are
four speed round questions and so
someone can be down three zip going into
the speed round but there's a chance to
pull it out because it's anybody's
ballgame once we hit that speed round
folks you ready to do this yes I am hell
let's rock and roll
first question of movie fights this week
was the 50th anniversary of Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey which got
us thinking what's the best science
fiction film of all time Wow that's it
it's a biggie it's a big old question
and let's start with Mark and Draco this
is gonna surprise people in the audience
but I picked the Empire Strikes Back
I think the Empire Strikes Back takes
all the old sort of goofy serials that
inspired George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg the original Star Wars is a
little goofy of itself as a little
cheaper this one is a great sequel in
that you can watch it and not ever watch
any other Star Wars movie and get a full
satisfying movie it takes all the cool
special effects and gives them emotion
this is the movie where you find out
spoiler alert
that Darth Vader is Luke's father this
is where the sparks start flying between
Leia and Han the first time this was
Yoda training Luke very much like a
Kurosawa film it's just a great great
great film that stands as a great second
part of a trilogy and it stands on its
own is a great science fiction movie
alright and drinko with Empire Strikes
Back Mike Carlson Hal I'd like to start
by looking up science fiction in the
merriam-webster dictionary and reading
it aloud just just for the heck of it
science fiction fiction dealing
principally with the impact of actual or
imagined science on Society or
individuals or having a scientific
factor as an essential orienting our E&T
component excuse me for that flub let me
make it very clear what my choices the
movie wall-e alright we all
remember this delightful tale of this
little trash compactor robot on a
garbage planet looking up at the stars
this is something this is a movie that
you know says something about the world
in which we are living today it makes a
point about consumption it makes a point
about having a sedentary lifestyle these
are thing
these are plot points and elements in
the movie that make a commentary on our
real world today and they do it in an
adorable amusing way with fun cgi
characters and here's the thing most
sci-fi is good it's fun but it does not
have the heart that wall-e does which i
think is the extra special weapon in
Wally's Arsenal it is a charming awesome
love story
I love wall-e it's the best science
fiction movie of all time okay there's
Mike Carlson Danielle Radford um I have
chosen which I think is the only true
answer is Terminator in Terminator 2 you
have both a machine who learns what it
means to become a person and what it
means to discover love and you also have
an elevated secondary character in the
character that is played by the who we
all love and she is amazing and we love
her and she should be the best thing
that ever happens to any of us and those
two elements are what I feel like make
sci-fi really pop sci-fi is about taking
machines or taking like these
supernatural elements these scientific
elements and figuring out where they fit
into our modern world and Terminator 2
did that for everyone all right Wow well
it's gonna be Judgment Day for all of
you right now fight it out all right
well Empire Strikes Back I don't want to
get into semantics here smort of a
fantasy movie though really science
fiction it doesn't really play with sort
of elements in the real world it just
sort of invents fun furry monsters and
we play like
like Star Wars they think oh that's the
series about fun for you I have to
disagree with you like Empire Strikes
Back is definitely a sci-fi film but
what it also is not is a complete film
because it says no lady that it also
picked a sequel in the middle of us
franchise no you can watch and enjoy
Empire Strikes Back with our and love
Terminator 2 Empire Strikes Back is very
very dependent on having known the rest
of it it know it begins on something
that you had to have known the previous
iteration of the series on and it ends
with a cliffhanger you have to know that
series in order to really enjoy Empire
it's a great movie that was the first
one I showed my nephew and he got
everything well your nephew is very
adorable and was probably very
influenced by how much these uncle loved
it um but it's no I'm just saying like
it's in order to really understand the
way that Empire works you have to
understand the entire series and so it's
not a standalone sci-fi movie whereas
with Terminator 2 even if you don't see
the first one because I didn't I didn't
see the first one when I first saw it
works for your Terminator 2 that you
didn't see the movie
it's a kid who has been through some
[ __ ] his mom has definitely been through
some [ __ ] and a terminator comes down
one day and then befriends him and
becomes as dad stepdad and then they
rescue his mom and his Malik you know
but we all have it and this is what
movie fights is about you see is a
different better movie than all of these
movies by movie in my mind it's more of
a heartwarming family tale than a self
i5 movie
even at the end look at the end of
Terminator when the Terminator does I'm
sorry I'm playing sad music in my head
and you're all feeling it in your voice
when the Terminator dies and sacrifices
himself it's because he finally learns
what it means to be human and that is
what sci-fi is about sci-fi it's parable
and sci-fi is about learning what it
means to like what is humanity what are
we what does it mean to be a robot what
does it mean to be an artificial
life-form what does it mean to be an
alien that is the core of sci-fi is
examining nobody's fired any shots at
Wally yet he doesn't really tell us a
Tasha nary tale of the future ant uses
fun characters oh we love what are
saying an emotional moment but what's
more emotional at the end of the movie
when Wally thinks that Eve is dead
spoiler alert I'm sorry Wally is a very
weird nice guy who's like well if I do
enough stuff for IVA then she'll love me
which is not true and not cool but also
Wally has like this weird fat-shaming
element of it where it's like oh when we
go up into the future world leader B&Q
san to like move an event Cheers
I'm fat hot chairs I also have a whole
last life and I'm doing the job that
most of you wish I would argue that
Wally I don't think Wally belongs in
this category because actually
Terminator 2 was my second choice for a
movie Wally how do I not belong in this
category cuz what I do think fat shaming
is part of it I think that's what it is
it's a metaphor for the chairs the
chairs that's a chair we become as we
get more technology we become more
passed a more sedentary so it was very
judgy it was a very judgy movie well I
think we described on an earlier episode
those chairs probably do a lot of weird
things to the people in them know show
those you can't argue what they probably
it's a subtext nice now
if they don't show what the chairs do
have the movies not really about I hear
about the robot so it's not really
giri's around like a goddamn rock tune
and scurries and looks for other Legris
it's adorable he's on the planet so
beautifully first of all what it was
what is Star Wars Empire Strikes Back
stay about I'm like our lives with what
that you shouldn't go in the snow it's
cold in the snow stay away from a
monster well know what Empire Strikes
Back says about our lives is that you
should watch you arguing you should know
you should watch the first movie and
then the third movie and that is what
Empire Strikes pecs is about our lives I
think that wall-e is a better all-around
movie than terminator I have obviously I
think Star Wars shouldn't be in the
category we're having a lot of semantics
I'm so sorry this is but I know but
people don't like it more arguing what
is a science fiction movie no I actually
do they do like it let me know in the
comments do you like it when we argue
about semantics I would like to know
anyway as I'm saying wall-e is a better
package it hits all of the things that
I'm saying and it does it with more
gusto you know at the end you're saying
an emotional moment when the Terminator
gives himself up that is not nearly as
emotional as emotional stuff in wall-e
we see it we see like the like we don't
even need to see Terminator 1 in order
to recognize that these humans are
terrified of this Terminator because
they think that he will hurt them and in
the end he [ __ ] has a soul and he
loves them and then he does the thumbs
up how dare you already surpassed Scott
manses amount of f-bombs that he have
said nothing obscene today wait all
right ok let's start with some final
thoughts mark and Drake I don't think
wall-e really fits in this category I
think well he's a great animated sci-fi
picture but I don't think it transcends
I don't think of the three of these it's
the least rewatchable I don't agree that
Terminator 2 is standalone like you're
saying that Empire Strikes Back isn't
because if you've never seen terminator
1 you have no investment Linda Hamilton
because she's so harsh and robotic in
that entire movie you have no past for
Star Wars this sequels elevated space
opera it has tons of emotional moments
yes it does down on a cliffhanger but
when I saw it when I was a kid a hundred
and fifty years ago I had to wait three
years for the next one
the movie gave you enough and and the
cliffhanger stuff it left it made you
want to figure that stuff out what's
gonna happen - Han are Leia and Han
gonna get the other is he really Luke's
father though those were those were
those were things that propelled you
that you wanted to know but you didn't
need to know to enjoy this movie all
right Mike Carlson final thoughts as I
was saying Empire Strikes Back I have
yet to hear something that actually
makes a commentary on the real world as
far as the movie is concerned and
Terminator look Terminator 2 is a great
movie but as I said it doesn't check all
the boxes wall-e is something that is
optimistic it is great it is beautifully
like just like let's talk about beauty
for a second this movie is more
beautiful and looks better than these
other two movies it's a work of art also
this movie I think is aided by the fact
that it is for all audiences sure so I'm
gonna hang Star Wars not part of it but
as far as terminator is concerned
children of all ages can't enjoy
terminator until they're of a certain
age and wall-e can be enjoyed by
everyone all right thank you Mike
Danielle well eternity or two was
definitely enjoyable by all by most
audiences and that is why they
introduced a fella that was a young John
Connor so that he could be the audience
surrogate into understanding this
Terminator the idea of the Terminator
isn't you don't need to watch the first
Terminator to understand what Lynda
Carter was doing oh you needed to
understand was that Lynda Carter was
willing to keep Hamilton
oh sorry Linda Hamilton was ready to
kill word be killed in service of [ __ ]
child and that is the part that's
important and the part that's important
is that this Terminator was programmed
in order to protect Lynda and that sweet
little precious by angel baby who only
wanted to imbue us with guns and Moses
lyrics and that was what like its it was
also in the same vein that it was made
for a doll
it was also made for children and for a
lot of things that were made for
children this one actually stuck and it
worked because I was a child when I
watched it and I believed it it time Wow
all right three great movies three
halfway-decent arguments before we chime
in with votes let's go to Dan Merle on
the fact-check well fans love all these
movies all three of them appear on
IMDb's top 250 lists so all three fan
favorites this does not play into my
decision it's just a fun as mike said
and this argument about star wars as a
sci-fi as a fantasy George Lucas said
that he did not consider Star Wars to be
science fiction he said it's much more
tuned to mythology to psychology into
history than it is to science however we
accepted the answer so that will not
play into my my decision however that is
technically the female robots name and
wall-e would be e he pronounces it as
Eva
but it's her given name and I don't know
how we ended up in a fight about the
best sci-fi movie ever arguing about
chairs again but I guess that's just
argue about chairs as a time that's who
we are now other than that we caught the
Lynda Carter thing during the fight so
thank you other than that we're good
thank you sir okay so yeah live in the
now we have three fighters and four
chairs so we're all good our legs will
atrophy so this is a difficult decision
like I said these are excellent movies I
mean I love all of these movies but one
has to reign supreme as the best science
fiction film in this argument
I felt like Mark you were taking a lot
of hits on Empire and you didn't tie it
in to the larger themes I thought Mike
introducing that definition did a lot
for him but it also did a lot for
Danielle and Danielle embrace that and
she broke down in I think
more specific terms than you did Mike
how Terminator 2 brought themes to life
and held a mirror up to society as far
as humanity and being a mother trying to
protect her son and t2 does have a lot
of that I there were some arguments
against Wally that I wasn't sure if they
were germane to what we're doing here as
far as you know the chairs and the fat
shaming but you did give me some food
for thought at the end of the day though
I feel like Danielle brought it home
with Terminator 2 so I'm going Danielle
on that one let's go to Dan Merle a very
difficult decision for me it came down
to I thought that two competitors got
very kind of stuck in a quagmire on some
very specific things about their movies
and I thought that one competitor
actually related it back to the question
back to the genre back to why it is
representative best of that genre and
that fighter for me was Mike so I'm
actually going to it's not not my
personal opinion but I think based on
the question and general argument I'm
going with Mike on this right on yeah it
was so we are locked up at one one Roth
cornet well it's time for the people to
speak and yeah hey Sal and they have
spoken the chat is alive with debate
other movies mentioned before I get to
the polling we'll get to it as alien
aliens Blade Runner play 2020 49 2001
children of mad arrival back to the
future twelve Monkeys and metropolis
keeping it old
semantics as well and whether Star Wars
is or is not a fantasy
I will break it down to these two
comments but Kerry Walker says semantics
are pedantic which I like that comment
and Brian malarkey says you know what we
need more semantics so there you have it
split decision on that okay this is
where they're at on the question pretty
close
Terminator 2 at 33% Empire Strikes Back
at 22% and wall-e 43% so Mike gets the
point Mike takes round okay hashtag
Botanica star geing into the lead
alright question number 2 a quiet place
opens on Friday directed by its lead
actor the offices John Krasinski WAP
who is the best he'll wrong question oh
okay my round 2 is different from your
round two you know what let's just make
it's not television okay let's just all
right flippy do okay
in honor of blockers what movie
character would you send to chaperone
your child on prom night
what movie character would you send to
chaperone your child on prom night and
it's round two so Mike Carlson you're
gonna go first okay first of all I want
to say that this question to me is a
very like a setup to send some sort of a
tough character that's gonna you know
intercept your son or daughter if they
get an opportunity mischief and I say no
that's not gonna happen because my son
or daughter they're gonna be raised
right they're gonna be responsible and
they're gonna be a little race in a very
sex positive environment okay they're
gonna understand what's the risks arm
they're gonna understand themselves
they're gonna be very comfortable so I'm
not so worried about sending maybe a
tough person there to like beat somebody
up which is why I have chosen falkor the
luckdragon from the neverending story
alright now let's talk about Falcor real
quick
first of all prom is expensive tuxes
dresses Joad flowers we know that that
stuff adds up so number one there these
kids are not going to need a limo
they're gonna ride to the prom on the
back of Falkor okay that is a pretty
cool way to get to prom and it by the
way very cheap because I'm close
personal friends with falkor the
luckdragon from the neverending story
and here's the thing once they're there
at the actual prom
Falkor it doesn't have to stand in the
corner like some old creep Falkor can
float above everyone and it leads to a
very cool strobing effect it's gonna be
of like a whole atmospheric thing at
this prom I think this is gonna be
wonderful all the kids there are gonna
appreciate Falkor and Falkor let's be
honest love's friendship and brings luck
falkor the luckdragon thanks Mike for
your never-ending answer
Danielle Radford um I chose I think the
only person that you could possibly
choose is [ __ ] Ripley Ripley look
Ripley from aliens is amazing and
obviously and I'll go ahead and say
because I know girl waiting for it
obviously she can be like get away from
ro you [ __ ] but also for first starters
you [ __ ] can be anyone you [ __ ] can it
can be gender-neutral if there is a
[ __ ] who is trying to be close to a
woman the nerf Li would let them but
also IED semantics but there is there is
no one who would be more supportive and
more protective of a group of children
than Ripley she has shown it on many
occasions if you give Ripley a child she
can't protect that child with her life
and you know what if some [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude is trying to like be real
weird with a child or with any kind of
child then they will just show up with a
mech all right mech suit to the prom
Daniel with Ripley mark and Draco I
picked Logan from the x-men franchise
because he would be one he wouldn't be
able to fit into the gymnasium - he's
actually fun to be around and three he
would not scare people away who'd be
there to protect the kid but if the kid
if the kid could explain to him why he
wanted to go hook up with someone he'd
probably cover for him cuz that's how
that's how Logan rolls he'd be the
perfect guy to protect your kids from
bad stuff but the one that if they feel
that he felt they were right would take
care of them I think that we're gonna be
a fun
he's like the cool uncle that you want
to have he won't achieve anything too
horrible but he's also not gonna like
just block you completely
alright Snicket he's thick any fire I
would send my child to go on on prom
night this is not about who would be the
[ __ ] coolest person that we get my
child hella laid give your kid a rubber
exactly and he's also the person that
would give my kid a lot of beer and
would be like oh hey you get to just
fight whoever you want to but yours is a
a woman with severe PTSD who would be a
helicopter mom she's like the
homeschooling mom yes I would send my
child it's not about who's the best
person I chose was someone I had a
dragon fit into the gymnasium first of
all a prom is not necessarily a
gymnasium like when it was mine it was
at a large Hayat ballroom and with that
dragon fitting the Hyatt Ballroom and
flower yes there was a utility entrance
that was big enough for Falkor go to
load it in
besides the the the venue for his prom
fat yes fat I will have to look the
address up at another time and again you
guys are and you're arguing all of these
semantics but at the end of the day it
is as apparent who could you trust the
question make sure that no one would
harm your child your child and make them
want to do even worse things why are you
man parent market helicopter parenting
this is too much supervision and this is
not enough supervision you're right in
the middle dragon and these kids want to
get lucky so he's gonna you're putting
your calcio back or does not have seat
belts there is no way except for
grabbing his furred those kids will be
safe you're sending a 16th fellow rider
luck dragon I'll glide accidentally go
upside down and then lose your son you
know your kids like thar the bubble kids
your kids are gonna be so hovered over
and so resilience the hats off of people
which is great for a mom Falkor has been
instructed to go only on side streets
and keep his level toward the street so
he's not too high up if not in
Schaumburg Illinois mark there are wide
streets there this is my kid we're
talking about my kid here okay they've
been raised differently than your kids
okay so how would your kid gonna stay on
falcore falcore is low to the ground and
he grabs the fur it's the beautiful fur
Falkor of course it also has some sort
of a binding thing to it he's made of
course entire thing was like hey hold on
I'm gonna go as fast as I can
he buzzes the tower of all of the
children that that kid went to school
with in order to scare them that is not
responsible differently doesn't scare
people at all purpose no fat poor did it
on purpose Falco was vegetable you want
this hovering mom to scare kids away but
she's not scary but fellow Cory's talk
about number of us Falkor was like this
we're [ __ ] her general introduction
to people that's reductions aliens that
might murder your child yes that is the
person that you're gonna be at the prom
we don't know yet is that a prom there's
going to be a sentinel attack let's be
honest he's not going to also good
friends with me in this scenario I'm
good friends with Falcons your friend
but it's literally like Falkor is going
into prom intentionally to scare other
children doesn't actually make your kids
till prom words two weeks before we
graduate all right a little variation on
the final thoughts the final argument I
want you to take us through a quick from
pick up to drop off what happens on your
prom keep it 30 seconds or less pick up
to drop off we're starting with Mike
Carlson okay well I have a magical horn
that summons Falkor so I go outside and
I play the horn and found horse shows up
and he's very low to the street there's
a party of about 16 kids because my son
or daughter very popular so they have a
lot of friends we take photos in front
of fail or a lot of the neighbors come
out and they're like oh wow I fell cords
back because he was just there for a
picnic on Sunday
cuz he's good friends with me so the
kids ride they're having a great time on
Falkor and also like it's open like so
there's no way to like sneak booze or
anything cuz he's an open there's no
compartment and his fur or anything and
they pull up at the problem of course
everyone's like oh cool you guys are the
coolest we just had a stupid limo and
like all so now my son or daughter
they're getting a lot of accolades
because they're like their dad is very
cool so
they get there and then Falkor goes
around the utility entrance where
they're bringing in the different
refreshments and one of the utility
workers opens a door Falco comes in and
he just sort of watch it's what happens
and he brings everyone good luck and I
say one last two less things yeah if
something goes out of hand he does
breathe fire so he can burn someone to
death if they'll get someone to play and
also I just want to say his eyes shine
with the beauty of a million stars
that's lovely thank you Mike Carlson
Danielle Radford what happens start to
finish your prom okay so what happens is
that my beautiful amazing adorable child
has been picturing prom for her entire
life and even though apparently in 20
years in the future some weird woman on
Odyssey calm or whatever is going to
write a whole thing about how she's like
well I was gonna marry that guy but it's
really great we digress a thing and so
Ripley comes up to her in a [ __ ]
spaceship and picks her up and is like
hey I got your dude
and my child is like this is weird it
feels weird that aunty Ripley is coming
to pick me up and then aunty Ripley the
spaceship turns into this big beautiful
mech that is also accommodating for a
prom dress and Aunty Ripley is like you
want to get in here and my child is like
more than I've ever won in anything in
the entire world oh my god Thank You
auntie Ripley and so my child climbs up
behind auntie Ripley because she has
never heard driver's license yet for
this kind of machine and there is behind
her a very adorable and terrified cute
young man who was like I don't know what
to do I don't know what to do I don't
know what to do and my child turns this
is hey it's okay we're just gonna walk
to prom in this thing in March and and
that kid goes do I get to operate the
mech and my kid goes now you dick then
she takes the controls or she controls
her auntie
as the controls and she's like but you
get to pretend with me this is great but
I have to cut you off because we haven't
even gotten to prom yet and we've been
going for a long time but yeah because
that's how magical it is but as someone
who wants a mech suit of their own I
appreciate that thank you yes thank you
and Drake a Wolverine to prom so it's my
kids senior prom and I remember when I
was a kid and was going to prom I wanted
to have enough freedom to do things but
I know my parents didn't want me to go
just rage so I send my kids Godfather
Logan with them because he's gonna be
there to protect them from something
really bad but he'll let them stretch
their wings because unlike some people I
don't want my kids to be these weird
little homeschooled sealed in plastic
human veal kids that are afraid to do
anything and must have a horrible mom
over them and I also don't want a giant
fire breathing dinosaur to destroy Jim
so I want this guy that seems cool
enough that he can be by the kids but
he'll be there to rein things in if they
got too out of control or too dangerous
and I'm not used three minutes to talk
since you said only 30 seconds thank you
Mark and Reiko all right Wow three very
different visions of prom let's go to
dad indeed dan how are the facts these
are all Falkor facts
Falkor comes from the German cuckoo er
which comes from the Japanese cuckoo are
you pal cor for the movie because it
sounds a little like what Danielle's
been saying the whole show
Falkor the model for Falkor was the
biggest model was about 50 feet long
that was the biggest model and I found
online some pictures of the Schaumburg
Illinois High School gymnasium trying to
be a tight fit but I do I'm making the
judgment that Falkor would fit inside
of course he well I don't know they
could fire on the ceiling of course he
but he could fit inside although Mike
also never specifically the question was
asked could Falkor fit inside he flies
around like it in the doughnut shape
yeah there you go
so there you go fantastic thank you for
that damn you've been over there the
whole time you know probably over there
for the rest of the fight but we're
talking to you why don't you go ahead
and weigh in first this was fairly easy
for me I felt like the Ripley kid would
never get to the prom and while while it
well I was like Lincoln that's a nice
argument I like the idea of uncle Logan
being there to me the whimsy for me I
think prom should be a magical night and
the whimsy of Mike's pick would make the
night even more magical so I'm gonna go
if alcor it's fine if you want your kid
to die Dan great that is one for Mike
Carlson I Danielle I like the idea of
RIP Ripley until it just I don't know
the more I thought about the more bleak
it became and then I don't understand
what this spaceship turned mech suit is
that was very confusing
you should watch some movies but it does
she have a spaceship that turns into her
own mech suit and so it came for me it
came down to and Draco and Carlson and
so this this did seem magical but you
painted a practical picture for me of of
the fun uncle I really grasped onto that
and then this guy will protect the kids
and maybe we'll give him a sip of booze
I don't want it like I want my kids to
you know have a little bit of fun but
not too much fun I think that's what
Logan would give them so my vote is for
an Draco but he won't choose one let's
go two rocks are locked up and the chat
is talking a lot about this a lot of
healthy debate again first of all just a
nice comment three of my favorite people
and fighters oh we agree
that was Patricia Carillo thank you for
her she was really 100% Joanna has a
concern or thought Marty McFly if he's
good enough to chaperone his own parents
he's gonna go for my fictional kid
Alexandria Miller I was gonna say Helen
Parr Elastigirl which is kind of like
the mix of everything you guys are
talking about Josh says I like Carlson's
train of thought and that most kids
won't need some trained assassin to
protect them so with that in mind I
choose Ian Malcolm strictly because I
think it'd be fun if my kids knew Jeff
Goldblum so it's both Ian Malcolm and
the actors in this scenario which I like
because you're getting two things at
once and Joby says you know the only
thing Mike that you're not thinking
about is Falkor is what its gonna do to
the hair have you considered hair in
this Joby or is that joke
Joby says I'm not sure that mike has
considered the hair implications however
having said that the rest of the people
with with you Mike because here is the
poll
Ripley 10% Wolverine 42% Falkor 46% you
charged out to a to tell you lead Wow
Wow Oh mark also you you might have
swayed maybe the voting audience if you
had mentioned the fact that Logan drives
a limousine but you don't want that
Logan to some really dangerous proms yes
the thing that I have noticed I didn't
actually go to prom the person they're
supposed to get a problem with slept
with my cousin's a sad story let's talk
more about
from the future all right moving on to
what was formerly question two but is
now question three fireplace opens on
Friday directed by its lead actor
offices John Krasinski who's the best
actor turned director must have been an
actor first the best actor turned
director and we're going to start on the
end with Danielle okay um so for me the
best actor turned director that I picked
was a banana flick and I know that there
there are many reasons that people might
disagree but I think that Ben Affleck is
a better director than he ever was an
actor and mostly than he ever was a
producer the movies that he has made
have been critically acclaimed as far as
an actor turned director goes and not
only were they critically acclaimed like
if you're looking at movies like Argo
which tell an amazing tale about a true
story you're looking at something the
town not a true story but also something
that was critically acclaimed Gone Baby
Gone everything that he has done as a
director and he doesn't he hasn't done
as much as maybe some of the other
people in these categories but all of
his movies so far have been critically
acclaimed and many of them nominated for
Oscars there you go thank you Danielle
back around a mark and Draco my pick was
Warren Beatty he may have only made five
films but he made four really great
films and one not so great film he Reds
which is an amazing film heaven can wait
or remake of the classic comedy that
still holds up to this day Bulworth
which is basically like watching a
documentary in today's world and one of
the first comic book movies comic strip
movies that embraced the the visuals of
comic strips in comics Dick Tracy a film
that is sorely underrated a film that
did most of its stuff with practical
special effects and was ahead of the
curve as far as the comic book movies we
had the Batman series from Tim Burton
then we had the Rockets here then we
have this
and Dick Tracy still holds up as an
amazing amazing film and he's been he's
won Best Director I believe one Mis
director once you want four Reds and
he's been nominated three times so he's
also very critically acclaimed a little
bit more so than Affleck all right Thank
You Morgan Draco Mike Carlson
sunday-monday Happy Days Tuesday
Wednesday happy days and so on and so I
could go on yeah there's several more
days there are more days
look Happy Days Andy Griffith Show this
is Ron Howard of course one of our great
sitcom actors of all time turned
director a man who floats under the
radar when it comes to directing I feel
like he does not get enough credit for
all the good movies he's made Apollo 13
beautiful mind even a movie like Rush
which people might not have seen is
still a good movie like this is a guy
who likes to be a chameleon when it
comes to being their director he doesn't
he doesn't you know he tries to adapt to
the material he tries to make everything
very different and look he's still in
the list late part of his career
probably about to have his biggest
success ever directing the Han Solo
movie I'm not saying critical success
I'm saying money success but this is a
guy who I think when you when you add up
all of the work he's done whether it's
acting also what are we by the way
debating are we debating the whole
package here nope we're debating Justin
directing okay great that's great cuz
that's perfect he has had so many great
movies that have touched people and when
you look through his IMDB you go oh he
directed that oh he directed that
Parenthood I forgot he directed that
this is a guy who's great he does not
get enough credit Ron Howard
all right write it out Warren Beatty
directed Heidi Montag says no to plastic
so I feel like we can go about films Ben
Affleck cheated on his wife with the
nanny no direct Ben Affleck cheated on
his wife that directed a short film
called I'd killed my lesbian wife and
got a three-picture deal with Disney did
you actually say it because I actually
watched Heidi Montag says no to
plasmasphere fault
the photo I know but it no it counts he
was a director if you want it to count
okay because it counts on IMDB it's
literally on ease pages of director and
it as much as it saddens me we can't
always count like people's producer
credits and that's what we do a lot for
Ron Howard I love ya but you forgot you
forgot this very specific movie out of
the four films Ben Affleck has directed
a movie called live by night that cost a
hundred and eighty million dollars that
has if he's such a good director he
should have a good idea about casting he
is the worst it's the worst performance
he's ever given it was a huge failure
that sent him into a spot that's a 25
percent 25 percent and he hasn't liked
look we're looking at Argo we're looking
at the town we're looking at Gone Baby
Bottle can't live by night that was
really compelling Beatles movie which
also for talking like we you know as
much as I love some of these other
movies they are not all winners I would
say I would say of the three directors
were talking about his movies or the
least real be watchable Ron Howard
arguably has a ton of history or
actually him is producer by research on
this one yeah as far as Ron Howard goes
Ron Howard has a lot of great movies but
he's also his run lately has been pretty
bad The Da Vinci Code movies the paper
the missing part of the see Ed TV the
Grinch
Ron I think the baby movie is probably
having it away tight when was that in
the 70s tight so Hitchcock
play the hitch I had a plethora of
movies Warren Beatty is still going one
Howard you still go or sorry I'm Ron
Howard is still going obviously as you
can say whatever you want to about him
but my choice is still going Warren
Beatty was gonna make what has been a
flicked on in last year's live by night
but Warren Beatty did that weird Howard
Hughes movie no one saw that looks like
it was shot on like an iPhone no one saw
no one saw half of half of Ron Howard
yeah are there better movies in the
newest Warren Beatty movie how much of
their product has been best it's not how
much of their product is like what has
he done since these questions the
question is the actor turned director
he's got kitschy movies like splash and
fun movies like movies more interesting
artists because he does so many
different types of things sure some of
them are gonna be amazing but no
thoughts Danielle my final thought on
Ben Affleck is that he was always going
into this because he wanted to be a
director and something that he talked
about all the time and when we think of
his directorial debuts Howard is debut
directorial moments how many of them do
we think of it or actually flops like
one my most effective out of four that's
only 25%
how many directorial like things have
there been from other people who you can
give anyone as much whatever they want
but Ben Affleck has been very consistent
in the movies he's done Argo that town
Gone Baby Gone
he has been a fantastic director all
right Thank You Danielle mark and Rico
Warren Beatty is not only Hollywood
royalty he made four fantastic films yes
he's had a couple of flubs but he's made
four films that are classics that are
rewatchable the Ben Affleck doesn't even
rate in this category
Ron Howard I
what argue was closer to this cuz
there's a couple movies of his that are
classic but if you look at his win-loss
record he's at about 50% there are about
50% of his movies that are utter
failures that no one that no one
remembers because they were so bad cuz
we want to think of Ron Howard as a good
director Warren Beatty has made great
movies has directed himself to an Oscar
nomination that's that has never
happened with this guy or this guy and
his movies were he's the most
rewatchable movies and the most
important movies of anybody in this
category thank you Mark like Ron Howard
was obviously given a spirit it was
given a lesson by people like Tom Bosley
people like Annie Griffith a lesson that
says you know work try things and work a
lot and I think it's a testament to him
that in his like sick he's got to be in
his mid to late 60's he's getting handed
a giant franchise movie like solo I
think that shows that this guy is still
at the top of his game you go through
his IMDB it's incredible the depth and
breadth of his work you don't even
remember as I said like he's got kitschy
comedies he's got dramas he's got
serious like historical pieces you got
like he's got trash like the Angels &
Demons he's got all of that stuff he's
got stuff your parents like he's got
some of the kids like I think when
you're talking about a guy he works a
lot but he's like Neela young okay Neil
Young puts out an album like every other
year sometimes it's awesome sometimes
it's okay and Ron Howard at worst is
okay and the best is awesome and amazing
he's got more better movies than all
both of these guys combined all right
there we have it let's go to Dan Murrow
on the fax yeah just a couple things
Warren Beatty had two Best Director
nominations for heaven can wait and Reds
he's been nominated four times for
writing but only two Best Direction
nominations Heidi Montag pseudoplastic
Ron Howard this listed as a director on
that one not not Warren Beatty had a
minute looking for that one that is Ron
Howard who's listed as a director on
that one factually those are my only two
clean ups for this fight no give you my
judgment great thank you sir
yeah there are films by all these
directors that I really like we
presented some strong arguments i yeah i
love Bulworth the Bulworth soundtrack is
off the charts that's good stuff you
don't like it it's great but it doesn't
count but it's also great okay I'm just
saying just that that's just a personal
preference
like that he mentioned Bulworth it
always makes me think okay but that
aside really it came down you started
arguing the better films which director
has the better library the better
winning percentage and that and Draco
really started to pull ahead but at the
end
Karlsson really reinforced for me just
how Ron Howard has made directing his
calling car and he just the way he's
been this consistent working director
and the body of work amassed which I
feel like Carlson really sold by the end
with the different types of films that
swayed me at the end of the day so I
gotta go Karlsson with Ron Howard thank
you even though great arguments for
everyone else Dan I felt a little bit
differently I felt that the failures on
the filmography which is something
that's gonna come up for any director
you choose I thought of all of the
fighters for me Marc was the only one
who made the best case for his director
in spite of their failures I feel like
both Mike and Danielle sort of tried to
shove theirs under the rug or pretend
like they didn't exist whereas Marc said
yes I will admit that yes I will admit
that the last one wasn't good but look
at it unbalanced with everything else
and I think that those make up for it
and as an argumentative tactic I thought
that he kind of outdid those two on that
metric and I also think he made a better
case for the overall quality of the
film's their importance so I'm actually
starting with Marc great it's one one
mark and Mike let's go to Ross listen to
the people here some other suggestions
were newcomers Jordan Peele and Greta
Gerwig from this past year Clint
Eastwood Sophia Coppola Jon Favreau Mel
Brooks random person says Rob Reiner had
an insane run with spinal tap stand by
me and princess by that's heart fried
that's hard to beat Benji the Builder
Minh said effing hell guys Charlie
Chaplin
that's a great pose well somebody's um
George says oh hi mark
poll says Warren Beatty 13% Ben Affleck
15% and Ron Howard with a resounding 71
precise to be fair that was the one
record they're gonna have it Mike
Carlson takes that round and he takes a
big 300 lead going into the speed round
no one of you will face him in the speed
round and we get to go sit down now
no no are sitting down by the way chairs
chairs are part of the show okay so we
are going to have a little tiebreaker
between and Draco and Danielle all right
so is there a hat for just okay choose a
number to it Danielle choosing over
between one and three to two okay
you know the same as the old we'll need
to cover no no nope
so Danielle you will have 20 seconds
okay 15 seconds nope
okay you have 15 seconds Danielle I get
to name actors who have played members
of the Conner family and Terminator
movies any actor who's played a Connor
in Terminator movies whenever you
whenever you're ready go Linda Hamilton
Linda Hamilton's son Connor Hamilton
Hamilton's grandson Linda Hamilton Jr
when Hamilton's third son time okay that
was one her name was named that - I did
the same question one no
one or three three three all right mark
you have 15 seconds to name actors who
were in the 2001 Ocean's eleven crew
begin Brad Pitt George Clooney you got
it it's time for the speed round
so yeah mark has to sweep the leg
brother you gotta sweep this whole thing
if Mike gets even one of our speed round
questions you go home a winner like this
no on his feet around speed round want
help my arm school okay
so again how speed round works there are
four speed round questions the first
person to chime in with their answer
gets to speak first they will get 20
seconds 20 seconds and then ten second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal okay
Roth will no longer be tallying your
votes she will be chiming in with her
own opinions as far as who wins each
point
okay broth you ready for that sweet
always alright it's mark versus Mike
let's do it first question of the speed
round
Steven Speilberg floated the idea of a
female Indiana Jones movie who should
play the female Indian Emma Stone Emily
Blunt you started to say you interrupt
it well what did he hit the desk yeah oh
you said it Emma Stone okay so I heard
your full answer first Emma Stone Emily
Blunt Millie blunt okay 20 seconds
begins whenever you speak mark part of
the fun of Indiana Jones and Harrison
Ford's great performance is that he's a
good-looking guy that women are gonna
like but he's not too good-looking that
men are gonna be threatened by him he's
an everyman in the best sense of the
word and the same thing with Emma Stone
she's pretty but she's not the Angelina
Jolie - gorgeous like it's a supermodel
she looks like she could be an
archaeologist and she get down and dirty
and she has a sense of humor about
herself and a likability that has a very
fearsome
I think all those things apply to Emily
Blunt but I think she has the thing that
Indiana Jones needs a stoic quality a
stuff quality of a little bit more of a
badass Emma Stone is awesome she's great
and stuff but I think as far as Emily
pond you're a little more scared of her
you're a little more sure that she can
kick somebody's ass she can go into a
temple she can raid things she can punch
a Nazi in the face that's something I I
see Emily Blunt doing more than I'm a
stone I see him a stone being funny I
just do not I think the likability
factor is huge there I think he's right
I mean Emily Blunt is a little too dark
she can do the dark violent stuff but
that's not the heart of indiana jones
indiana jones as an adventurer that we
can relate to and i think i'm a stone as
far more relatable
i think Emma Emily Blair has got a
whip-smart wit I mean I think that's why
she's Mary Poppins she's got a she's a
character that has warmth but it's
inside it's internalized that's what
Annie Anna Jones is all about that's
what Harrison Ford was Emma Stone is
great but I see him time alright Wow
Emma versus Emily
Ross talk to us you know I thought I
loved both those choices actually but
Marc for me made the argument about why
Emma Stone would fit as that character
in this case I would have to go with
Marc sure that's 104 Marc for two great
arguments and two different takes on the
character I love Marc's kind of argument
about the approachability the kind of
every person quality that Emma Stone has
and how that's Harrison Ford but I also
liked Mike's take that Emily Blunt can
kind of do the down and dirty work of
being Indiana Jones I this is literally
almost 50/50 but I I think I'm gonna
lean slightly towards Mike but I think
they're two great arguments okay one one
I feel like Roth really crystallized
what I was thinking
I thought Marc made the better argument
as to why Emma Stone would embody the
spirit of that character better markets
the point and we got ourselves a ball
game it's 3-1 so I was oh sorry
I don't actually vote in this okay do
you want a thing to say everyone would
you picked I'm honestly both of you
great thank you
all right question number two of the
speed round John boyega says he'd be
open to joining the MCU which Marvel
characters should boyega play blade
Deathlok okay blade Deathlok we heard
from Mike first Mike 20 seconds begins
whenever you speak blade is an awesome
character and we need boyega he's an
awesome he's a star so obviously there's
not gonna be a death lock movie before a
blade movie blade he's got to come back
and he's got to be better and ever and I
think that boy Anka can say a lot
without actually doing a lot of dialogue
he has both the range to be like a very
talkative character but also a guy that
can say a lot with a look and that's
sort of what you need with play that's
what a cool thing that Wesley Snipes was
able to do is that make this guy badass
but say a lot with your face unlike
unlike Deathlok blade as a character
that is so imprinted on Wesley Snipes
John boyega could take a character that
doesn't have any baggage and make it his
own Deathlok is the Terminator meets
blade he can do actor that with a look
and act with silence and he is such an
expressive face and the torment and
stuff that he could bring to that blade
is such a glib character where Deathlok
has a tragic quality to him that makes
us want to root for him I think boyega
is great at playing glib I think we need
a character that has to has to use some
of boyega's natural skills I also think
just like we want this guy to be a star
in the movie we don't want him to be
like a weird agents of shield character
because that's where they're using
Deathlok also too the problem with blade
is blade is definitely a hard our
character and Disney Marvel Cinematic
Universe are never gonna make a hard-r
character without the language blade is
blood Deathlok can be a future movie
Deathlok can be the Terminator with
superheroes time Wow oh what a throwdown
let's go to Dan Moreau Marc I think took
this one for me I think it just the kid
that not having the baggage attached to
that character you can do something
dynamic Wesley Snipes imprinting so
strongly on blade I'm gonna I'm gonna
side with Marc here okay that's one for
Marc Roth that was really tough because
Mike had a great argument for why boyega
would be great as this character and
also I have to say I'm weighing in he's
how deaf Hawk is currently being used
he's right you know if you're gonna use
Wagga you want him to being a starring
role but overall I think Marc me the
stronger point about creating a
character that we haven't seen yet and
how he could be used so I'm gonna give
it to Marc - BAM mark and Draco making
this a real contest it's three two again
if Mike takes this next point it's over
but Marc and Rico on a run in the speed
or
let's go to question number three dr.
evil returned on The Tonight Show better
Michael Myers SNL comedian and star of
Wayne's World or serial murder and star
of the Halloween franchise I sent out
Halloween okay we heard SNL and
Halloween Mike Carlson who spoke first
Michael Myers the murderer he's killed
people he's burning a ton of bad movies
Mike Myers has created some of the best
characters that we love sure then a
couple of missteps but Austin Powers and
Wayne and wait um you know you kidding
me this guy's one of the funniest people
he's a hero to millions of meze out
there who wanted to be funny he is a
beloved person Michael Myers as scary as
a Halloween costume once in a while but
when Obon is an attachment to him like
they do with the best Mike Myers I
completely disagree Mike Myers on
Saturday Night Live if you read the
Vanity Fair article stole a lot of his
jokes and abandoned his friend after
doing Wayne and Garth he's a joke thief
and he's made horrible choices since his
two good movies a decade ago Michael
Myers in a horror movie is one of the
most iconic characters and one of the
scariest movies ever made thus they keep
trying to reboot it because that
character has stayed with us and talking
about Halloween masks what did they wear
in baby driver there are way worse
Michael Myers movies and there are Mike
Myers movies okay and I'm saying there
are better more different Halloween
costumes you can be sprockets you can be
Wayne you can be the little guy in the
bath makalah
give me any of you admittedly some
really bad give me the busta rhymes
Halloween Resurrection movie / the Guru
/ so I married an axe murderer or over
in hosting the Gong SHINee 10 more
seconds valve time Wow oh boy you know
what great first rounds but then I feel
like you just macheted yourself a la
Michael Myers Mike Carlson
when you were describing all of the at
where you use most of your rebuttal to
describe all of the Halloween characters
you could dress the horse Mike Myers SNL
characters the kid in the bath that
Simon is the characters names yes doll
that song Keys dohsa
okay we're not good we're not here to
dissect the SNL behind-the-scenes gossip
but I'm giving my point to mark and
Draco on this one let's go wrong oh man
this one is another really really tough
one cuz he both made some compelling
arguments but I think that mark yeah he
just made the best argument about why
this is an iconic Halloween costume so I
guess he was down three oh he's tied
three-three burn and Draco charges back
into this game
Wow hey see this next point this next
point will determine our winner look
good look to you
Santos mm-hmm has demanded that fans not
spoil the infinity war mm-hmm what's the
most ridiculous infinity war spoiler you
can think the most ridiculous and Vinnie
more spoiler I have question about the
question okay I'll hear it do you mean
ridiculous like something that we think
might actually happen or something
ridiculous like funny either way either
way either
Thanos marries the black widow Santos
marries the black widow the most
ridiculous spoiler would be that years
prior to the movie a creature a race of
creatures that are Shrek like an
appearance have infiltrated the moral
universe and they've secretly been
living in the Marvel Universe as the
heroes so Captain America Iron Man they
all take off ahead in the middle of the
movie to reveal shrek and all of the
heroes are actually Shrek's okay the the
shrek characters versus Thanos marries
the black widow you know what we asked
for ridiculous and we got ridiculous
mark you spoke first you go first mine
is really ridiculous because Thanos
marrying Scarlett Johansson is just
plainly ridiculous what Mike just
described is actually what's gonna
happen in Avengers 4 except it's not
gonna be Shrek it's gonna be the scrolls
and it's called Secret Invasion so he
just replaced something that's actually
potentially a real spoiler and that's
are they're going to recast everything
can you imagine 90 foot tall fan hose
and tiny little Scarlett Johansson
getting married it's like beetlejuice
and uh and Winona Ryder it's hilarious
and it'll never happen
alright imagine you're in the middle of
watching this in on IMAX and Tony Stark
flies in with you to confront Thanos and
he's like hey I'm Shrek and then he lets
a big fart out okay everyone will be
like what the hell this is insane
first of all how did they get the
license is there some sort of DreamWorks
Marvel thing people will be wondering
about that and all of a sudden all the
heroes take strikes and now there's a
whole army of Shrek's about to attack
top once again he's just taking an
actual plot point and placing it with
Shrek I don't know if that really is if
there's any real plot thing there it's
like saying you know what if what if
guardians were all caterpillars it's not
really just there's no thought process
that would be crazier than your idea of
all of them were caterpillars people
would blow up their blinds boom but if
you hear a thing about it
Shrek and then of course where's donkey
donkey appears in Avengers 4 that would
be the next logical step so we know time
quite a slowdown and yes it lived up to
the ridiculous part of the question
let's go to Rafa I gotta say that the
one for me the that really fulfilled the
promise of ridiculous has to be Mike I
mean that is a ridiculous insane spoiler
so I would have to give him point okay
104 Mike Karl dunky dunky is always the
next logical choice yeah everybody loves
a doctor dimension Dan I felt like Mike
was a little bit of a one-trick pony
though Shrek and March right it's just
Secret Invasion but with Shrek's Marx
was one ridiculous enough for me to that
combined with this counter-argument for
me to give it to Marc and send it to you
okay Wow
this truly is a great moment in sports
coming down from 300 to tie up 3-3 in
the sport of movie fighting you know I
was full I love a donkey reference think
and that the Shrek choice was I think a
pretty ridiculous choice but aunt Draco
really got in my head talking about the
how that is simply renaming the
characters who could appear in Avengers
4 and because mark just like got in my
head and gave me pause I thought about
his his was appropriately ridiculous so
man mark and wrinkled with a comeback
victory
[Applause]
well lied one of the great comebacks and
movie finds history mark and Draco how
do you feel after a comeback like that
oh this was fun I was a little nervous
it's been a while on with the new
formats and formats changes but this was
actually really fun I don't think we
yelled too much we didn't get too dirty
these speedrun questions were actually
really great I think that whenever I do
movie fights before it was always fun
when the answer is other people chose
where answers that you didn't get so we
were all arguing against things that we
kind of liked and that's always the most
fun and we saw that we are all three
really passionate about movies and I
thought it was a really this was I would
have liked to watch this one this one
was really fun well beauty the beauty of
YouTube can go home and watch it later
today tell us where we can find you
oh you find me on Facebook and on
Twitter and I will be appearing at San
Diego Con Motor City Con in Novi
Michigan in May
hmm where else I think that's it great
thank you mark and drink Oh Congrats
what a victory Mike Carlson well fought
very entertaining but tell everybody
where they can find you buddy I am fat
Carlson PHH there it is on the screen
Twitter and listen to podcast the ride
at podcasts the ride and Twitter and
give us a relic Oh rady likes a nice
comment to review it iTunes cuz that
helps us is a great awesome I Danielle
thank you for bringing the fun and the
funny and the mute and the movie
knowledge talk to us tell them where you
can find you um you can find me at
Danielle Radford on the Twitter you
could also find me on tides and fights
which is my weekly wrestling podcast
which I love so much you can find me
here like literally every Thursday I
just kind of live here um and also yeah
I can you all are doing so good with
finding me on on the Instagram so I can
start getting these fat lady
sponsorships keep going Thank You
Danielle Dan Moreau
thank you for holding it down on the
facts and the whatnot thank you for
following the script for the show that
we pre-rigged towel yet we're into
everyone watching live despite not
knowing what anyone is going to say yes
yeah we are this is not rigged we go by
the the bylaws of the International yeah
we'd be in front of the movies like hey
Dan we don't rig this no
[Music]
dan anything else any other exciting
news notes I'm sort of find you yeah
here over on SJ news screen juggies news
every morning and every day doing
reviews with Roth we just put one up for
a quiet place don't check out now yeah
really good movie that you should check
out this weekend and all around the
other channels you know here generally
heck yeah uh thank you sir
Roth Cornett pleasure having you here
this was fun as always there is a lot of
amazing donkey Marvel fanfic happening
in the chat that I encourage you all to
continue on the Twitter's Thank You Roth
and we'll finally I want to thank you
for watching movie fights I'm al Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram and
hit us along thank you for watching bye
bye - sweet